so today I will talk about how to
accelerate Cloud chaining with elastio
basically how could we make our gpus
busy
and already introduced me so I will skip
this slides
so for today's agenda I will talk about
what is Alaska and its process API
basically how can we without modifying
our training screen access data in our
cloud storage and then I will talk about
the three levels of how to accelerate
cloud training with Lazio how to
accelerate our cloud storage degree and
how to combine the data preprocessing
and changing together and then how to
make other computes and closets storage
connect together to become a data
attrition layer for our whole chaining
process
so first about the Alaska is poses API
for some of you guys that may not
familiar with alacio alacio is a data
alteration layer for analytics and AI in
the cloud basically on the top of Alaska
you can run different like different
compute ETL and chaining Frameworks
especially the tensorflow and Pi torch
and underlying elastio connects to all
the different kind of story systems
including the popular like S3 Azure and
other hdfs clusters and Alaska basically
creating a unifying namespace for you
for all the compute and training
Frameworks to assess different cloud
storage and providing caching abilities
so that's because we provide different
interfaces for connecting to different
like compute Frameworks for example we
provide the process interface for our
cloud training especially tensorflow and
Pi touch
and Alaska provides data caching
capability so for example our training
and our computer may be on the cloud and
our data storage may be remote or maybe
in a remote like hdfs cluster or maybe
the remote cloud storage so by using a
Lazio we can we can basically like get
the data from our remote object storage
and cache the data locally to provide
local performance for repeated data
access
as similar for metadata we can also
catch the metadata locally
and for Alaska process API basically a
Lazio create a unified namespace for
different storage systems and a lasso
poses API May one step further we can
assess different cloud storage not using
a lost sales apis but using our Standard
Process API like the mega directory
nkdir command LS command and all the
linkage commands that you guys are
familiar with
and all the training Frameworks like
high touch tensorflow can directly
assess those data just like your local
files and directories
so for example for here we we can mount
different story systems to one elastic
namespace among the Alaska namespace to
our local folder for example the local
directory Alaska here it looks like it's
just a local folder but it could
represent all the different cloud
storage systems so maybe one data set is
a data set in hdfs and the other data is
a other folder represents the data set
in our S3 or azure
so
so I'm not nests which are about like
how to accelerate our cloud training
with Alessio after we knowing that
Alaska provides such like uh unifying
space process API and other
functionalities
so for round one we how can we
accelerate the under storage data assess
so in this one uh basically like
sometimes our data set is already ready
in our under storage and we can directly
use it for training so in this case our
training may need to load the data the
same data is a multiple times repeatedly
and to do our training job to tune the
parameter or do other things and in this
case if every chaining requirement or
the data array or the other like get
file status cost if we all those scores
need to go directly from under storage
that will create a huge bot basically a
huge burden for our under storage
especially like the concurrency can be
like a large amount of operations per
second and it will really make our
understands not stable so Ultra storage
May limit your access rate and some hdfs
and self may be unstable and provide low
performance and in this case if we can
use lasso to to get the data the whole
data itself from our under storage once
and then store in Alaska to basically
catch in elastic cluster and then
provide to our training clusters then
the later access will be much faster
basically Alaska is not just next to our
training cluster and the more training
cluster you have the more training job
you have you can you can scale basically
scale up the elastic cluster or scale
Down based on your need
and the usage is relatively simple we
start a last year cluster and we use one
command to mount our S3 data set
providing some of the S3 credentials and
then we can mount the S3 to our elastion
namespace and then we can use one
command to load all the training data
into Alaska and after the distribute low
command all the data located in our RC
data set will be cached by Alessio and
provide data locality for training jobs
so maybe that's chew a little too big so
we use a concrete example from Microsoft
they have more than 400 tasks need to
read data from Azure and write data back
to Azure and the total data set is
larger than one terabyte and the total
nodes is more than thousands of nodes so
previously they copied the whole one
terabyte data to each of the changing
nodes and the whole read request could
be met with much larger than one
terabyte and by using this approach they
are really easy to exceed the azure's
request rate and just as you just say
that oh I cannot provide you more data
so they just give you an arrow error and
then all them or basically the maybe one
or several of the copy job will be felt
and in this case it's relatively hard
for us to identify that okay which of
the data is uh which nodes didn't copy
successfully and then all the changing
jobs need to wait for all the nodes to
have the data locally and data ready
locally so the GPU will be idle when we
are doing all those operations so kind
of like the copy process is kind of like
like long and based off of our resources
as error prom
and what they do is that they use a
lasso in the backend to for the data
catching and by using a lasso basically
the training job you don't need to wait
for our uh data to be ready local to
start your training job last year
asynchronously doing the data loading in
the back end so that the training job
can be stopped in the beginning and
while waiting for data to load in the
backhand so we can see from the left
side graph before using a lasso the
first line a bunch of time are just
waiting for data to be ready and the
last time I lost maybe 30 minutes or
maybe several hours are also waiting for
the data to be written back to our cloud
storage and doing that the data training
is fine but the data processing data i o
operations the stage of IO read and I'll
write makes our GPU utilization
really low
and by using a lasso because we are
doing the streaming right in the three
and right in the back end so we can see
the GPU utilization rate is really
stable from from beginning to end
and because we're streaming the real
request and we reduce a lot of
re-request so we are unlikely to see the
cloud story requests array so it's less
Pro error prom
okay now we talk about uh after we talk
about how to accelerate our Cloud
chaining and from cloud storage
basically how to accelerate the cloud
story and then we talk about how to
combine the data pre-processing and
changing together
remember one assumption in the previous
round is that our data set is already
ready to be used in our cloud storage
but that not always be the case we need
to do many of the heavy data
preprocessing like the transformation or
other stuff like before we are ready to
use the data set for training so in this
case how can we use elastio to combine
the data preprocessing and Chinese
together as we are the whole process and
for data pre-processing there are
multiple ways and first we talk about
how to use like spot link to do some bit
data ETL and then use chaining to use
those pre-processed data
so for Boss dripping they have a use
case that they use bufflink to
pre-process data and they need to do
model training on top of the
pre-processed data the original solution
is that the youth staff is a persistent
storage they they write the
pre-processed data into stuff and then
model training directory read those data
from self and multiple problems are
found here first or not only all the
persistent data that persists to
self-under storage but all the temporary
files like the transformation file
during the ETL stage may have many
temporary files and all those files will
also be written to yourself and cost
self under really high pressure and
those data doesn't does not need to be
persisted on the other hand our training
will keep reading data from itself and
especially like our training is really
heavy so one popular data set may be
used for multiple training clusters
especially when we are training the
parameters and in this case our staff
will also under really huge pressure and
we cannot control the self rewrite
pressure so the cluster is really
unstable and we always want our
presented data storage with as stable as
possible to make sure that our data is
really safe
and so then so the solution that they
are coming with is losing Allah still in
between our compute chaining and also
our under storage
so basically they use the sparkling to
do the data preprocessing and all the
temporary file is written to Alaska and
all the predicted data basically the
data preprocess result that available
for our training will be right to Alaska
and Alaska will be persist those data to
staff and hdfs for long-term persistent
storage and those data set will be
directly returned to our do our model
training and the more model training the
more elastic the bigger the Alaska
cluster to support those training like
burst workloads
and in this way we can keep our
understory stable
so basically in this way we can improve
our understory stability basically the
temporary files will not return to the
under storage and also more training job
we launched we have a bigger Alaska
cluster to support the burst workloads
and we can speed out the whole process
from data preprocessing to chaining our
elastic cluster can be put closer to our
compute and training jobs and as long as
the data is ready in Alaska our training
job can be redated from our Alaska
cluster Alaska can do the data
persistence in the background
asynchronously so this presentation
stage will not block our training jobs
and we can just launch more elastic
clusters of bigger clusters to meet the
burst ETL or training requirements
and in the other case uh sometimes we
will use some C plus or python discrete
to do our data preprocessing and in this
way we can also use elastio to speed up
the whole process the Alaska can help
you to load data from different like
under storage and data pre-processing
like screens will read those data from
Alessio pre-process it and written back
to Alaska and provide to training and
this thing Willow is is really similar
just to the ETL one so it's stimulus
lead to our users
so in the last one uh we talked about
how can we speed up the data education
layer
so in this one just no matter what our
data set is it may be a radiator set in
our under storage or it may be need to
do some data pre-processing using some
bit data ETL tools like sparkling or
using some stringing screws like C plus
plus and python to do some data
preprocessing uh all those data sets can
be directly reached through to to load
below by Alaska and provide the caching
capability for our training jobs so the
training jobs can read the data
repeatedly from elastio to speed up the
whole training process
and similarly for right all the
temporary files can be temporarily
cached by a Lazio for future usage and
all the persistent data can be directly
right to Alessio and persist to
different account under storage you can
also configure like multiple under
storage if you want
so basically Alaska can be used as a
data operation layer for analytics and
AI in the cloud different compute
different training job assess data from
different cloud storage Alaska provides
caching capability to move our data
closer to our compute and changing jobs
to speed other data assessed
so in Momo Momo has multiple Alaska
clusters including like thousands of
illustrial nodes and storing more than
100 plus terabytes of data a lot of
mainly serves the searching and chaining
tasks of momo and Momos they still did
continue to develop new use cases over
last year especially the training use
cases and they use as mainly because
Allah still supports multiple under
storage and multiple compute engineering
Frameworks in their case they have
different kinds of compute jobs and they
want to persist data to different under
storage so that they can easily switch
from cloud storage a to cloud storage b
or from one cell or hdfs cluster to
another cluster they can easily do those
switch and they want you use us to
accelerate their compute and chaining
tasks I know that they have like they
want to make their user have super fast
experience oh oh so before we talk about
all the detail Momo is kind of the
Tinder in China basically and this and
by and by using elastio they can also
reduce the metadata and data over half
of the under storage
they have huge amount of user base
this may be similar to Tinder user base
so and also like uh the moment they also
develop some changing use case use cases
they have used Alaska to do the billions
of image chaining they have like two
billions of small files and their stack
is the first that's partouch with stuff
and now they add a lasso in between to
reduce the metadata and data interaction
with staff to improve the
self-performance and also improve our
data reading performance
and they also use a lasso to do some of
the recommendation systems model loading
basically the other model to hdfs and
it's really load the model from hdfs to
elastio and the recommended system the
they may have hundreds of nodes and
those nodes will directly load the model
from Alaska concurrently considering
that if the low is directly happening
hdfs it may be gives hdfs a really huge
pressure and but if they are loading
from elacio elastio is think that you
can add and remove based on the needs so
they just add more elicio cluster or and
mod nodes to be out there they took
their system or model loading and
similarly they use lasso for am system
in desk loading
so in summary uh Alessio may help you if
you have one of a multiple of the
following cases if you have degree
chaining if you have just single no
chaining with a small data set you don't
need really need to use elastio you can
basically just copy the data to your
chaining node and then do the chaining
it's super quick so Alaska is helpful if
you have distribute chaining and if you
have a large amount of data set
especially when the data set cannot be
fit in your local storage then you can
use a lasso to do a distribute chaining
to to have a distributed catching
cluster for your training jobs and and
it's especially helpful if you are
network IO cannot certified with your
GPU requirement so many class doors
nowadays provide their cluster refuse
solution but their Network aisle may not
be satisfied and also
um their class dollars may have some
request limit and in this case you may
consider catching the whole digital cell
closer to your training jobs to fulfill
your GPU requirements and we find
especially useful when the users have
multiple data resources and multiple
training and compute Frameworks
basically if you use sparkling for ETL
and you use tensorflow and Spark
tensorflow and Pi touch for chaining in
this case Alaska can be a unifying space
and in between to connect the different
light training jobs and compute jobs
together and if you have multiple data
storage to read the data set from or
maybe write the data set to then last
year is helpful for managing those data
read and write requests
and many users from us because their
under storage is unstable facing the
high concurrent chaining request so they
found us to reduce their uh to basically
media on the storage more stable
especially men when meeting the first
requests and also to avoid the cloud
storage request rate EC problems
and also lie in the changing job maybe
like in the maybe some companies they
have some debtors that they are really
heavy they basically use the data set
for multiple training clusters multiple
teams share the same date yourself in
this case the if the infra team provides
some of the infra to catch those data in
another cluster for their for those like
training tasks that it can that it can
reduce under storage load and also the
details that can be shared by those
different tasks
just like what Microsoft did
and uh in the year I want to release
that our community so this uh this
project the Alaska Fields Alaska post's
API project it's not a top-down a total
disease Edition from the Alaska
Community open source Community it's
basically our open source uh users they
fast and say that hey uh our training
job they need to load some data for our
cloud storage and we found that the
change job can the CPU basically is Idle
we can only use our GPU to like maybe 50
of the GPU and it's really low and it's
unsettable and the fast to say that hey
we think that maybe elastio can be used
in this environment can be used for
training because many people of you guys
may not know that Alaska previously is
designed for
hdfs and for Presto and Spark for
analytics workloads and they found us to
say that we think that Alonso maybe can
use in AI training and why not we have a
try and then we try Alaska still in the
AI machine learning
only scenarios and in the beginning it
doesn't work that well but we prove that
it can be used it can maybe improve a
little bit of GPU but not much because
sorry because we are not directly
designed for AI machine learning but as
the time goes we iterate our solution
with all those complete users and they
they give us idea of like uh how they
assess status through their training
jobs and give us feedback and iterate
the products with us and then to make
this product gradually become more
mature and now it's in production in
Microsoft job and many of the open
source companies
and for about how to deploy and use uh
feel free to check out our last year
they talk that available at alaska.io
Alaska they uh webpage and then on there
we have many times to talk about like
how to actually use a lot of supports
this API and how to deploy a lotion on
kubernetes and all the other related
talks about basically how to accelerate
your compute job your ETL job and your
training jobs and for the process API
specifically feel free to check the
Alaska process API webpage directly
Google like Alessio posts API and you
can find it
and and we have many of the talks like
this one will be available in our we
will share our last year website a lot
of the io website and share what our
social media like our teacher alastio
linking and we have a Channel and
slack channel is mainly for like
technical discussion and also when you
have problems you want to get help from
then you can also allow us to talk to us
from slack since live we have like
engineer from all around the world to
answer your questions to help you to
figure out your progress and whether a
loss your official need and whether you
have some problems running Alaska oh um
or any questions or just talking you can
also like just talking to us through
sulak uh any questions so far
uh definitely talk
okay thanks Lou uh thanks a lot for such
a great talk
and uh
I don't think we have any questions yet
so yeah I mean
thanks a lot
you guys have any questions offline then
just go to our order I think the I this
call is really great so I will also
watch question there